hey this is e here for geek culture
we're here at the Xbox
it looks like Pirates of the Caribbean
part seven eight or nine and over what
they're on right now what is the
full-blown
hoedown with the old banjo I hope they
have some something for their scurvy
this is this is Molly
this is all one of their highlight
titles they showed off and you're
supposed to get together with a band of
other parts and do different objectives
maybe one of them is just like throwing
down
and of course in case in this glorious
plastic security where they store
magneto is the new xbox 1x in all its
full glory behind here in this other
fish tank you can see the Xbox one X
when it's torn down into the different
layers and that is the Cyberdyne ship
that controls it all you got some heat
sinks very nice and this is of course is
the most powerful console that they
release but in its smallest form factor
six terabytes I don't know how they
squeeze out all into there now what can
you do with six teraflops of pure
processing power you can power
4:07 Motorsport that is their new
driving game of course they did announce
that they had eSports aspect to it but
that is being played on a curved 4k LED
screen that is the dream for a lot of
gamers and of course that has a
hydraulics that makes it seem like
you're actually in the car
look at that that is a rig right there
and of course as we go into the booth we
have a preview of some of the other
games they just announced 42 at launch
some of the bigger ones include lucky
you can see that it had won the best of
e3 idea nominee a nice platform with a
new Fox character oh
my goodness and right here we have the
game that I've been waiting for
Dragon Ball fighters and they're like
kicking people out people can't even get
in here that's how hot this game is
that's what I'm looking forward to anime
in its finest and
check this out this dude
thinks he's going to play so long that
he brought a 24 hour 24 pack of water
because you sold thirsty for that game
minecraft
moving on over here we have a Madden
2018 and we've got some Assassin's Creed
origins that is the secret of the
Brotherhood and how it all started not a
very big title but I'm
the Darwin project only the strong
survive speaking of the strongest this
is the strongest woman in all of Asia
Alicia heads up
hey
no we're geek culture now but we can
change and then moving on to the back
over here this is where they do a lot of
the broadcast this is their new
streaming platform a mixer you can
stream in 4k if you have a lovely beard
like that gentleman look at that camera
I wish I could sell on that but we're on
a iPhone and a gimbal because there's
still very low budget hopefully we can
upgrade our systems now here is a very
nice area or you can actually customize
the controller that you use for the Xbox
one
I'm sorry
line is super long but as you can see in
the back there a very reminiscent of
Nike lab where you can design your own
shoes everything can be customized from
the d-pad to the analog pads and
individual buttons the triggers so I
think there's over like a billion
combination of what you can do you can
even get it engraved with you know made
here in III and I think some of them are
really limited ition as you can see from
the long line over here
of course another big selling point of
the Xbox one is its compatibility with
the Windows 10 system so here you see
really ridiculous custom Cassy's I mean
it looks like a Decepticon
running on ridiculous cooling
thermaltake
wow this is a built by a customizer in
Brazil another one over here very lovely
the ports on this open up this is insane
and of course we'll be going here you
can see a lot of the partner laptops
that
Xbox is teamed up with you got the
Predators original
Alienware
as use all those big PC names
excuse me
rounding out here is a even more game
when we talk about a clock sweep and the
franchise this is the one that really
put it on its map halo now in its a
latest form Halo Wars - another big line
for this one
now this is a close up of the actual
trip that is driving those six teraflops
under the hood the cyber darkness was to
take control of the console wars
for the f1 and
as this barrel and this treasure chest
might suggest here we are in the sea of
use area where you can team up with
different people and go on treasure
hunts at different pirate missions
trying to get in through there
see of a/c use we got a chance to play
that check our other video for that
hello neighbor path of exile man they're
really going all out on the ski of these
opening up the test I think those are
an eye patch over here
follow Xbox and all the socials
Instagram the bird the squid the
Facebook and the YouTube
and
just to show you how important see if
these is to the Xbox one X launch you
can see they've gone for the whole
shebang if it's higher to the Caribbean
what time are they on now number eight
or number nine I'm losing count pull on
chains and barrel and there you have it
this is the Xbox one booth here at e3
this is the final day come on down it's
your last chance to get your hands on
the game the the queues are very long
but if you are patient and ambitious you
definitely can get your paws on check it
out and this is our report here on the
floor for geek culture